foreign
[Music]
don't be scared
we've met before
are you looking for Reagan are you
looking for Reagan
Trainor
[Music]
what do you think evil is
I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and a desire to be happy
it's happening to my daughter
the devil has one wish Wherever those
girls went they've brought something
back with him
to make us lose faith I believe you can
help get our daughters back did you live
in this and the devil never gives up
she knows who I am
where's the other girl
[Music]
what you're doing here is
these people have died on both sides of
possession
come on baby
mama what is it baby
I'm right here I don't wanna go to hell
oh
there are two heartbeats isn't working
they're beating in sync
what did you do
one girl lives one girl dies
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I have a job for you
the cake really
[Music]
good
security gig
hello
welcome to Freddy's
you met them yet
who
foxy
Bonnie Chica Freddy
foreign
what is this that's why the place shut
down
research Freddy's hey they never found
the kids
[Music]
ghost children
possessing giant robots tell me how to
stop them
you don't it's too late
oh he's coming
[Music]
foreign
thank you
there's something wrong with the school
something doesn't feel right
so if you what happened
there's something here
that's not meant to be
[Applause]
what are you doing
she's standing there
this thing it's come back for me
this demon was once an angel
rejected by God
stripped of power
it wants that power back
it's okay to be scared I'm scared too
you send that thing back to hell
[Music]
this evil is something different
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
first place I learned about gas was pet
some dirt
[Music]
the secret place
generation to Generation Dead things
buried in that land
but come back
there's something else
[Applause]
[Music]
can you hear them
voices
I think something's wrong with Jimmy he
needs time to adjust
the people built to pet cemetery to
protect them from evil
something's talking driven
foreign
[Music]
sometimes dead is better
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life
John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much gun do I have
months at best
I still have a lot of work that needs to
be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
you all pretended to cure me but what I
have planned for each of you is very
real
yeah
the only thing I have not provided is
your anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
out of all the men to choose you picked
John Kramer please don't hesitate place
a big enough piece of your cerebral
tissue into the glass enzyme tank this
will save your life
this is not retribution it's a
Reawakening
[Music]
live or die the choice is yours
thank you
Alice engaging with trolls is like the
worst possible use of your energy
[Music]
since you joined BuzzFeed your art got
super lame and you're dying a fire
don't judge me and sometimes you gotta
troll the trolls
[Music]
good
thank you
do you know how to find out who this
handle belongs to you really think a
weird account is haunting your apartment
here David who is only 10 and his mother
went insane
is your son
in a coma
Dr Landers
[Music]
oh my God
you've seen my son David I'm having you
what does he want asking yourself
foreign
[Music]
Salem they didn't teach us all our
history
some stories got lost along the way
maybe if they had taught us everything
that happened my brother would have left
that knife where he found it
I will play I won't quit
you know what I think we should do right
now go to the party come on let's go
if you play with me then I'll let you go
to your party and I won't call Mom okay
Joe
what game do you want to play
[Music]
camera you'll all say I will play I
won't quit
tell me demon
am I it
morgas
what did you do let's play
Marcus
how are you ready to play hide and seek
Marcus why do you have that knife bye
why are you doing this
go what is going on it's not him it's
the knife
found you
hey buddy you're just messing with us
right how about something
it only happens when you wins
what if we win only one way to find out
I will play
I will play it I won't quit
now
let's play a new game
I'd like to report a crime that hasn't
happened yet have you seen the movie
Back to the Future basically I'm living
that movie right now which is how I know
there's gonna be a murder tonight
hate time travel movies they never make
any sense
[Music]
for this time of year is for us your
friends were murdered 35 years ago it's
not 1987 anymore stay safe honey I love
you
what the [__]
excuse me what year is it 1987. oh my
God I know the 80s are almost over and I
haven't even tried Coke yet
I don't know
oh my God Mom
[__] off and die Jesus mom
um
[Applause]
[__] nowhere what's the big deal
there is a murderer on the loose and you
drove us into the woods
I forgot to bring vodka
you have seven and a half hours until
you're stuck here forever
before it happens
kill us all no they more just rip apart
the fabric of our society via dance
videos on Tick Tock they stand against
us
come on out water's warm just so you
know I don't do [__] you pee out of
that thing
I think
you did do [__]
it'll be alive
yeah let's not make that the lesson
[Music]
80s read sucks this is just dirt look at
all these Twigs I could give you a gummy
this big it has 100 times more weed than
this
[Music]
[Applause]
have you seen the group chat I'm doing
it again tonight
no please what's my mom's Remembrance
Day I just want to forget about it huh
foreign
[Music]
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
like the candle to open the door
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
oh
what does the hand feel like
it felt amazing I could see and feel
everything on the other side
so my mom she was trying to reach out
Point here
still been saying stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God they followed us
they're not gonna stop you're never
gonna stop
I like you
[Music]
laughs
I've found something
I've looked at it from Every Which Way I
Am the smartest person I ever met and I
can't figure it out so I came to the
second you are up to something my friend
is so cold
sake
spot the con I can't
detective you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the Dead
I give all I have to hear my daughter's
voice
and wants to be heard we are here
listening
um
Felicia
what is happening
[Music]
[Applause]
your contract is there
somebody is dead no one shall leave this
place until I know who did it a ghost
killed her
there must be our rational answer for
all of this
just admit that you are up against
something bigger than you no
[Music]
you were saying
something in this house tried to kill me
don't look at me like I'm suspect we're
old friends every murderer is somebody's
old friend
no one shall leave until I find if the
living have been killed by the Dead
you have been hiding here all this time
who are you talking to
it's Halloween
you know what that means
all Sawtooth Jack is gonna rise from the
corn fields It's gotta be stopped
kill or be killed you've all heard the
stories
we failed at our duties and that black
dust destroyed our crops Our Lives
it must die
so we can live
your sacred Duty
is to take down Sawtooth Jack before
that church bell rings at midnight you
really think that's real I saw it
it's real
he saw it
did you kill it
then let's go kill it
[Music]
you should do it you know I'm not
allowed just because your brother won
the run last year
I got an idea
if that thing isn't dead by midnight
this whole town is going straight to
hell
I want to go home I don't want to go
home you think you're special why are
you doing this
if you're born in this town
you're cursed I'm ending this
tonight
it ain't over
[Music]
I don't think I'm gonna do that tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
together
hello Joe
let's discuss your new job
I got a wife she's pregnant please let
me go
your work consists of pushing the mill
failure to meet your daily quota will
result in a punishment
the employee with the fewest points will
be terminated
[Applause]
you are well on your way
still don't believe the rules apply to
you
perhaps you would respond to other
incentives
[Music]
what is this please you're still asking
questions walk through the door prepare
your mind for a transformative
experience by mallard
[Music]
your official part of our team for life
with you
you're all true it lives inside
foreign
[Music]
laughs
countless reports of arson and vandalism
a state of emergency as violence reaches
historic levels go knock them dead then
revive them again and just keep like an
endless loop you're gonna be riding with
Jason
15 years on the job you do a lot worse
awful stabbing of one male party 412
Broadway okay here we go let's move okay
all right he kills the cop
drops the car here
puts the body in the front seat who does
that
[Music]
oh my God keeping up Trace from some
type of accelerator this was intentional
these are messages bro
[Applause]
we get what we deserve
[Music]
thank you
Harper has his first new zombie movie
coming out in over 30 years no one knows
anything about it except it'll Premiere
here exclusively in carverville
Halloween night
is the projector ready
[Music]
do you need anything else no start the
movie
what is this
you just roll the film and it turns the
actors into the Living Dead
power to suck the souls out of everyone
in this vicinity we can stop them from
spreading as Marion had all the
knowledge if he were here he'd know what
to do your films must be burnt you have
to destroy them all go to the theater
stop the projector that's the last film
no freaking way
I just got my driver's license you can
drive
[Applause]
away from it
[Music]
hit him on the head
we're in really big trouble we'll never
watch another zombie movie again
hurry up
[Music]
oh
God can you drive
have you seen my kid
should have been home an hour ago your
mom's gonna be very upset with you
I love your costume which right oh it's
not a costume I was sweeping the floor
okay fine one month detention please
[Music]